No,
I am Fred Wilson and I am the managing
partner of Union square ventures.
It's been changing the way I work for
the past 15 years.
I see it as an,
as an evolution,
not really a revolution.
So,
uh,
I think every year there are two or
three new things that I use as part of
my daily life that I wasn't using the
year before.
Um,
and uh,
you know,
I think social media,
whether it be blogging or I'm a social
networking or things at the intersection
of blogging and social networking,
like twittering and so on and so forth,
these are becoming incredibly more
valuable to me as business tools.
And they were two or three years ago,
uh,
I've used the phone less and less
everyday.
I used to say that when I got into the
business,
uh,
in the mid eighties,
the phone was the way that I did 80
percent of my work by the mid nineties,
email had become the dominant form of
the way I did most of my work.
And the phone had gone down
substantially.
Now social media and blogging and
twittering and things like that have,
have,
have become the highest form of the way
I do my work.
Email has come down relatively speaking
in value and the phone is almost
completely gone from the tool set that I
use to get stuff done now.
Face to face interaction has been a
constant.
So,
um,
I see,
I don't think that has changed one bit,
you know,
going to a board meeting or having a
face to face meeting with an
entrepreneur,
um,
in order to decide whether we want to
make an investment is as valuable or
more valuable today than it was 20 or 30
years ago.
Um,
so that hasn't lost any value,
but the phone has come way,
way down and now I see email coming down
a lot too.
I think that several things going on,
I think that,
uh,
the,
that this generation is going to be a,
a very different kind of workforce and
the workforce that businesses have known
in the past,
I think they will be a lot less loyal to
businesses.
They will be.
I'm interested in maximizing the value
of their career as opposed to the value
of the stock of the company that they're
working for it,
unless they control that stock or own a
big piece of it.
So I think that the,
we're looking at,
I'm very much immersed,
mercenary,
mercenary workforce.
Uh,
we've already seen that in the
technology business for the past 10
years,
particularly among software developers
in Silicon Valley.
You know,
there's,
you know,
the best software engineers are
constantly getting poached from company
to company company and getting better
and better deals along the way in the
same way that a,
I'm a film star or a music recording
star would be constantly being offered a
better and better contract to go work
for somebody new.
Same thing's happening with software
engineers and I think that that kind of
mindset about talent is what this
younger generation's all about.
And so they're all going to be about
building their own personal brand and
their own personal career,
their own personal portfolio of what
they can do.
And then they can make themselves
available to the market,
to the highest bidder.
Well,
so for us,
the biggest impact and in the companies
that we've backed is that,
uh,
we can hire somebody,
um,
who is the best person for the job,
uh,
if they are not necessarily willing to
locate.
I'm taking here in New York City.
So we have companies in New York City
that have a software engineers all over
the world.
We have people in New York City that
have product managers or whole customer
services organizations in another
location.
Um,
you can put
your,
your high labor cost workforce somewhere
else than where your headquarters is and
uh,
and,
and make it work.
I mean,
and this has obviously been going on for
a long time,
but this is a trend that will continue,
uh,
for,
for all forever probably,
uh,
I have been profoundly affected by this.
I write a web log that is read by about
100,000 people a month.
And,
uh,
within that group I'd say there's
probably about 20,000 people who are
sort of the most hardcore,
you know,
committed participants in that
community.
And I really mean community.
These people do meet ups,
they comment on my blog,
they have offline conversations with
each other,
they meet each other,
they go and do startups together,
says this community that exists,
I consider probably at least a thousand
of these people friends,
and yet I have met um,
and advisors,
right?
Um,
and I've maybe met 100 or 200 of them,
um,
but I'll get emails from people who I've
been communicating with and dialoguing
with for three or four years saying,
you know,
you need to go visit this company.
I saw what they were doing yesterday and
it's,
it's absolutely revolutionary and,
and I'll go do it even though I've never
met this person because I,
I know who they are.
I've been able to develop a relationship
with them online.
I've had conversations with them and
discussions and debates and uh,
and that's brand new that has never
existed in the world of business.
And we are leveraging that in our
business.
And I think that lots of people are
leveraging it in all different kinds of
businesses.
Businesses are starting to engage with
their customers using these tools in
ways that they've never done before and
they're starting to get feedback from
their customers in terms of what's
working and what's not working,
what products are good and what products
are not good,
what people in their organizations are
good and what people in organizations
are not good.
And um,
and people are starting to develop a
level of trust around this kind of blind
or anonymous or semi anonymous kind of
communication that they didn't trust
five or 10 years ago because it was so
new.
But now people are seeing,
yeah,
I can trust that kind of feedback even
though I'm not getting it in,
in a traditional way.
So it's been going on.
Last time programmers have been using
something called IRC,
which is Internet relay chat.
Um,
and they're these sort of form your own
chat rooms.
And so what programming teams have done
for the better part of 10 or 15,
maybe 20 years is they all come in in
the morning and one person's in,
you know,
Vancouver,
Canada and one person's in New York
City.
And one person's in,
in Buenos Aires and another person's in
Bangalore,
they all come into this IRC chat room
and they're writing code and talking to
each other at the same time.
And they're saying,
yeah,
how do I hit this database?
What,
what's the,
what's the query I need to use?
And the person who has the database guy
in Bangladesh has,
oh,
you write this query this way.
So they're collaborating using these
online tools.
So that's been going on for a long time
now for um,
you know,
a marketing organization that's not as
Geeky,
you know,
that's not a,
a good way for them to work,
but they can use a Wiki,
which is basically a website that exists
inside the firewall and outside the
firewall they can post questions to it
that's happening.
Um,
and there are,
uh,
there are even companies that are using
facebook groups I'm in,
which is kind of a public group,
but people are using that even for
businesses.
So there are a hundreds,
if not thousands of different tools that
exists for businesses to do these kinds
of things.
And um,
more,
more being developed every day.